[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAX COPPIN: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Well, thank you for
joining me here.
Well done for finding your
way over from [INAUDIBLE].
You've passed the first test.
I'm sure it feels like it's
been a long day already,
particularly for those of
you like me who've come from
slightly further east,
as you can probably
tell by the accent.
So my name is Max Coppin.
I'm based in our London office.
I work where our Android
Enterprise efforts are based.
Just to give you a
bit of background,
I've had, counting it up,
about 15 years of experience
in various different mobile
technology companies,
various different roles.
So developer through to
admin, various different sort
of experiences of
different technologies,
back from the days when
mobile email was exciting.
Push email was yet
to be a thing, which
now seems like a very,
very long time ago
and makes me feel
very old indeed.
But I'm going to take you
through the strategies
around Android and
Chrome, how you
can use some of
these technologies
hopefully to improve your
enterprise experience.
Just a quick look
at the agenda--
so we're going to look at some
research and some analysis
from some of the leading
companies in this space.
A bit around
strategy development,
selecting and
deploying the tools.
Some examples of where
some of our partners
have really embraced this.
And then last, but by no means
least, some of the resources
that we have to help you
go and replicate this
in your organization.
So we've got some research
from our friends at CCS Insight
that I'm sure some of you
are familiar with that we're
going to use here.
So really, we're
looking at the maturity
levels of organizations.
And this is real spread from
some very kind of basic,
if you like, sort of
elementary levels of deployment
right through to, as
hopefully you can see,
some of the more
advanced technologies
and really kind of
transformational type solutions
that companies are
looking to put out there.
So what we see really
is that there's
a big step change
between these-- well,
it can be a big step change
between these different steps,
these different stages.
And there are a few
points that we'll
call out that really aid that.
So this center of excellence
you can see in the middle
is something that often
gets pointed at as, say,
a way in which you can really
help move organizations
through these different stages.
And we'll come on to numbers
that back that up in a minute,
but really the idea of giving
employees a place to go to get
help in terms of deploying a
mobile solution and that kind
of thing.
The other area that
we hear of as kind
of particularly key and
very important going forward
is the idea of
when you're getting
to high levels of maturity of
really measuring that success
and not just measuring adoption.
You know, we deployed
application x to whatever
percentage of employees, but
the real kind of business impact
of that, how that actually
changed the business,
saved time, that kind of thing.
And the other interesting
insight that we see quite a lot
is there's a pretty clear
alignment between a company
success and their
actual maturity level
here so that there
really is kind
of a lot of proof
around business
success and mobility maturity.
So if we take a look at some
more research around these kind
of apps that typically
used, the first column
shows really these more common
sort of collaboration apps.
I think there's a bit
of a question mark,
really, as to whether
these are going
to be the sort of
IT-deployed, corporately
managed applications, or whether
they're more sort of guerrilla
IT or whatever you
want to call it,
but consumerization
of IT type deployments
where employees are
using the apps maybe
in a kind of an
unsanctioned way.
But then as we move
through, we get
to these kind of occasional--
typically it seems to be sort
of approvals or like emergency
access type applications.
And really, it's only the kind
of single-digit percentages
in this rare section, which
is where hopefully everyone's
trying to get to, but
it's the particularly
small number of applications
being adopted there.
So those are the really kind
of line-of-business, more
transformational applications
that have been deployed.
But there's another
kind of question
that we'll come onto a
bit later, which is really
around this
relationship between IT
and the employee in terms who's
driving the adoption, who's
making the decisions, who holds
the budget, all the things that
are, I guess, points of friction
and potentially contention.
So a few other numbers to
run through around this.
So average number of apps
used by employees for work
is apparently 4.1.
I don't know what that 0.1
overlap is, but there you go.
But apparently 86%
of employees say
that they do use or do regularly
use applications at work.
But it's just that 4.1
is the average number
of different apps
that they're using.
Now, that number's obviously
something that we predict
or certainly Gartner predicts to
increase hugely over the years.
There is one stat
that I've heard
or one prediction I've heard
that sounds rather scary
is that they talked about the
idea of the average company
producing 1,400 new apps
by 2024, which sounds
like a kind of extraordinary
number, a kind of scary number,
a bit of an extreme number
[INAUDIBLE] whatever
it is, around 200 a year.
And it will be five
times more than IT can
cope with in terms of demand.
So great news.
Isn't that just what you
wanted to hear on a Wednesday
afternoon?
But it's an extraordinary
number, given that in--
I think it's 2016,
[INAUDIBLE] did
a survey where they said
80% of the organizations
that they work with only have
less than 10 applications
deployed.
So there's this
huge curve coming,
and a whole load of
challenges and complexities
associated with that.
Quite where all these
applications are
going to get written and who's
going to do all that developing
is another good question.
Although, if anyone has a kid--
anyone got kids under 3?
Stick your hand in the air.
Just me?
There we go, a few there.
Have you ever heard of the
Fisher Price Coda-a-pillar?
Be scared.
Be very scared.
It's a coding toy, and to
teach kids from three years
on to code, so very scary.
I'm sure my daughter will
be looking forward to that.
So a huge uptake in
applications, and a huge uptake
in the increase in the speed
at which these applications are
going to be developed, which is
another kind of challenge when
you look at the
typical enterprise
deployment or development cycles
are sort of 18 to 24 months.
Whereas now, you're
seeing requirements
where you're looking
at weeks and even days
in terms of deployment cycles.
So again, Gartner's
prediction is
to look at this
bimodal approach where
you say we're going to have some
applications that are typically
more like legacy,
longstanding applications
that we're going to develop
with one methodology.
And then we're going to go more
agile for something that maybe
is tied to a specific
event, or has
a finite lifetime
and a completely
different set of requirements.
So 41% of employees
say mobile has already
changed the way they work.
That kind of makes me think
it's possibly a little bit low,
but again, those
previous numbers
suggest that it's going to
change pretty drastically
over the coming years.
And this is something that maybe
backs up that previous number
and where the change
is going to come from.
So 76% of employees have not
asked their IT department
to provide apps for work.
So why do you think that is?
75% of them said they
would not ask IT,
because IT would say no or
ignore their request, so quite
a simple answer, but
quite a challenging one
when you think if IT are kind
of seen as blocking, then
what typically happens is we'll
see employees go around IT
and find their own
way of doing things.
It's the scenario of, I want to
be able to annotate that PDF.
You're not going to give
me the tools to do it,
so I'll forward it
to my personal email.
And then I'll go and do
it on my personal device
or whatever it is.
And suddenly you're out of
that kind of sphere of control.
So there's good reasons for
trying to help employees
through these challenges.
And so the lack of
a formal process
for requesting
applications really
seems to be the big challenge.
Really at least having a
way of allowing employees
to request apps helps
shape your demand
in terms of types
of applications,
in terms of volumes,
and helps you really
segment users and all
these best practices
around determining what it
is that you need to start
providing to your employees.
Anything where you're getting
numbers to back up decisions
is always going to
be a good thing.
So 72% of employees do not
have a company app store.
So I think here there's
a lot of user behavior
and so on from
the consumer world
where you have an application
to do just about anything.
And you go to your store.
You search for whatever it
is, whatever hotel you're in
or airline or city.
And you type in whatever
it is, and you'll
find an application for it.
And that's typically how
users find applications.
If you don't have that set
up within your organization,
then how are users going
to find the application?
And I think what we've
certainly seen from the Google
side historically is that the
first thing that an enterprise
would try and do would be to
block access to Google Play
and distribute
apps their own way.
And I'll come on to
it a little bit later
about how we can negate the need
to do that and deliver a much
better application experience.
So when we look at this
sort of market and the types
of applications out
there, as we've seen,
the bulk of applications,
they're really just kind
of packaged,
off-the-shelf, SaaS--
I'm extending some
existing application--
It may be collaboration
or that kind of thing.
Moving up through those steps
is this existing maybe approval
mobilization, desktop
process, et cetera, et cetera.
The top is where we
really aspire to get to
and where I think the
most benefit can be had.
And these are
typically applications
that are maybe mobile-first
or even mobile-only
where you're really
taking advantage
of the power of the
device to deliver
a very different,
unique, and again,
transformational experience.
So with that in mind, there's
one bit of information
that never seems
to change around
importance in terms of
spend, and security is always
up there.
Mobility always seems to go
hand-in-hand with security.
It opens up arguably
a number of other--
or certainly used to open up a
number of other attack vectors,
and this kind of thing.
And I think--
I'd like to think that
things have moved on
slightly from where we were a
few years ago, in that security
used to be very much
a blocker in mobility
and that we could
not deploy devices,
applications,
whatever, because there
is no secure way of doing it.
I'd like to think we've
kind of got beyond that now
and that there is
a way of doing it.
There may be sort of
regulatory or other kind
of reasons around that, that
adds the complexity to it.
But I think really
that we don't really
see, based on
conversations that we
have with customers,
security actually
stopping the deployment.
I think a lot of the reason that
security is a priority going
forward is around some of
the new legislation coming
in-- so things like GDPR, which
hopefully you're familiar with.
If not, go and google it--
a plug for our search friends.
But go and have a look at that.
And that has some pretty
strict requirements
around reporting
of data breaches
and this kind of
thing, which are
going to drive some changes
in security and mobility usage
patterns.
So there's a number of
different analysis firms
and reports have
talked about how
Android's going to rise
in the enterprise world.
It's going to really
change things going forward
in terms of not just replacing
typical knowledge worker,
BlackBerry deployments,
but also in the kind of--
these are all
different use cases
and line-of-business,
purpose-built, rugged, et
cetera type deployments.
Some of you might have seen
my colleague presenting
on this kind of thing earlier.
But that's where there's a huge,
I guess, area of opportunity
to tick off a lot of
those boxes in terms
of big ticket, really
important enterprise
changing application
deployments.
So not just, what was
I doing at the desk.
Now I don't need to
do it at the desk--
really going beyond that.
And there's a whole slew
of feature requirements,
these newer technologies, that
I guess are not immediately
things that are thought of
as enterprise technologies,
but things like
voice and assistance
and so on where if you're
looking at a device that
is going to be operated
by someone with gloves
in extreme conditions
and so on, they're
not going to be able
to necessarily use
even a keyboard, let
alone a touch screen.
And so embracing technologies
like voice control and so on
can really help that.
And there's a huge
range of Android devices
out there, which I'm sure
for a lot of you would have
historically seen as
a bit of a challenge
and a bit of a problem.
And the F word always
used to come up--
"fragmentation."
Nothing more extreme
than that, before I get
bleeped on the video.
But that's something
that, again, we'll
talk about in a minute
how we've hopefully
solved and kind of flattened
out that landscape for you,
and made it really
easy to deploy
a range of different
[INAUDIBLE] devices
across the organization for
completely different use cases.
So in terms of strategy
development, there's a--
I could go on forever,
really, with a list
of things to consider here.
What is the aim, and
why are you doing this,
and who are we doing
it for are things
that may sound straightforward
and silly questions,
but I think that
often get ignored,
because it's easy to skip
too far down the line
and go, right, what's
our IT strategy?
Well, we already kind of
know where we want to get to.
And let's just work
back from there.
And where we want to get to.
Maybe something a bit
more basic around maybe
deploying MDM or whatever.
But really by going
through these questions
and looking at what
we're trying to do
I think is a really
key way of doing it.
The other interesting
thing we always hear
is around what stage
companies think they're at.
So hands up here who would say
they've got an IT strategy.
Anyone confident enough
to say that they've one,
or even have written down one?
I mean, that's the other
thing that we really don't see
much of is people documenting
and iterating on that document.
Period of time it needs to cover
is another interesting one.
I mean, typically, businesses
may have a one-year strategy,
and an IT strategy's going to
be over three to five years.
Aligning business
and IT strategy
are pretty key, but not
necessarily achieved,
particularly with staff
turnover and so on--
another good reason for
documenting these things.
And measuring results and
iterating-- so like I say,
measuring the success
and the change
that you're having,
not just the adoption.
So my favorite
examples of what's
not a strategy, which are
all scenarios that I've
had personal experience of--
the days of
BlackBerry panic where
everyone had to throw
a BlackBerry into all
of their senior employees'
hands because the law firm
next door was doing it.
It's not really a strategy.
It's a sort of
reactionary tactic
to try and often get
a bit of appeasement.
"I need to get the CEO's iPad
working" was another famous--
I think it was one
Christmas where
it seemed like every
CEO, CIO, et cetera,
went home, got an
iPad, threw it at IT,
who then went, oh god, what
are we going to do with this
and how are we going
to get this working?
And that generally moved
into the bottom state
of, I need to be
able to lock, locate,
wipe all these devices,
and then that challenge
of personal devices moving
into enterprise world,
the whole scenario
of whole-device wipe.
And that lead into containers
and that kind of thing.
I know I genuinely have had a
conversation with a company who
were that kind of one
company who seemed to be
the one who were being taken--
I think actually taken
to court by someone
because they wiped
their device, and it had
pictures of their cat on it.
So it really does happen.
It's not just that
kind of example
that people who are trying to
sell you a container solution
talk about.
So a few other
considerations on this slide.
So engage the line of business.
So I'd say think outside
of the IT department,
and get out there and work
with these line of business.
There's one company
that we've been
doing some work with where--
an airline who were
looking at what
they can do around working
with their employees.
And they've gone to the extent
of a number of their IT staff
have trained as cabin crew so
they can go out and experience
what the cabin crew
experience, and better
understand the
kind of challenges
that they're going through.
So that might be quite
an extreme example,
but it's a very good example
of living the business problem
rather than working it through
in the confines of the IT
department.
And often working
with business--
this phrase of
"citizen developers,"
which I'm sure you've heard of--
all these kids who grew
up with their Fisher Price
Coda-a-pillar and
move into companies
and start writing applications
to solve business problems.
Going back to those numbers
that we saw earlier,
it's really that
scenario of, if there
isn't an application supplied to
me to solve that problem, I'll
go and write my own, if I don't
have a good way of requesting
that from IT and so on.
So if someone's motivated
enough to write an application
and solve the
problem themselves,
then that's someone that you
really should be working with.
Survey data are,
again, kind of key--
so not just the feedback form,
how did you find this device,
was this application
useful, but you
can go a level deeper and
look at the actual analytics
within applications.
What are people doing?
If you're deploying
an application,
what are they doing
within the application?
Which screens are they
spending their time on?
What are the actual actions
that they're going through?
It's very easy using a number
of our tools and others
to collect that data and
do the analytics there.
And avoiding these what
are called top-drawer
deployments where you go, great.
Thank you.
Thank you, IT, for giving
me this wonderful tool.
I'm going to stick
it in the top drawer
because you've turned
this wonderful smartphone
into essentially the
internet-connected paper weight
and it's now no use to me.
So again, some
basic-sounding things,
but often somewhat
overlooked-- what
are the outcomes going to be?
So we should have a
tool that is really
going to help our
employees do a better job.
It does raise a whole
other set of questions
around who chooses the
tool, who's responsible,
who pays for it.
And often, these
are decisions that
are more led by regional
variations, legislation,
and so on.
But there's a whole
bunch of reasons
that we'll come
into, how you could
work through these challenges.
So moving on on tool selection.
So we've got a whole bunch
of Google devices running
a couple of different OSs, or
a few different OSs out there
that are essentially,
as one of my colleagues
always calls them--
or at least he did until the
[INAUDIBLE] came around--
glowing rectangles.
So you choose your
glowing rectangle.
You leverage the power
of the cloud, which
you've heard so much
about this morning,
and our various
different services there
in order to deploy
whatever application
it is that you're trying to
deploy and solve whatever
problem you're trying to solve.
So if we drill down into what
that means in terms of Android
and Chrome world, we've got
a whole range of devices
to cover, every price
point, use case,
from these convertible tablets
to rugged devices that you
can drive over and so on.
So if we look at what that
means in the Android world,
I mentioned earlier
the F word and what
we've done to try
and improve that,
that challenge that we gave
to you guys historically.
And I think that
the main message now
is that if you go out and
acquire an Android device,
as long as it has GMS, the
Google Mobile Services,
on there, then it will have all
of the enterprise capabilities
that you'll need baked
into the platform.
So that's the work
that we've been doing--
fully integrating
this into the platform
and enabling a number of
our ecosystem partners
to really leverage
that technology.
So starting with Lollipop,
we introduced this
into the framework around the
support for the device owner
and a separate managed
work profile on the device.
And that was really
the core of what was
introduced into the framework.
With Marshmallow, we introduced
some APIs, what we call COSU.
So it's Corporate-Owned,
Singe-Use deployment-- so
really, a kind of rugged,
line-of-business kiosk device.
Call it what you will.
Choose your own
acronym, but a device
that is going to be really
aimed for a single purpose
and only running one
or two applications.
And then we step through to
[? N. ?] And obviously, we'll
continue on to O, just adding
really incremental features
and improving a lot
around the user experience
and those sort of things.
Now along side that, we've done
a lot of work on Google Play.
So I mentioned earlier
how the first thing
that a lot of IT
departments would do
would be to block Play, take
it off devices somehow, disable
it, and deploy
applications another way.
Well, some of you may have
caught Adrian's talk earlier,
but Play is actually
a very powerful tool
for enterprise security now.
So one of the key things that
we're trying to avoid companies
having to do is enable unknown
sources on their devices,
so this idea of
sidelining applications
that don't come from Play.
And the reason for
that is because any
of the applications
that go through Play
go through a huge amount of
scanning that is increasingly
leveraging our machine
learning capabilities
and so on and so forth to ensure
that these applications are
trusted, secure applications.
So we support a number of
other features in terms
of [INAUDIBLE] purchase
and managed configuration--
so this idea of rather
than presenting a user
with an application
which they then
need to enter a user name and
a server address and a port
and a whole load of config
info, which they're either going
to get wrong and
drive support calls,
or not do and therefore
not use the app, we now
have a consistent
way of ISVs allowing
their applications to be
configured across the board
by an EMS.
So all of these
features are essentially
leveraged by whichever EMM
is used, be that G Suite
or be it one of the many
partners that we have.
The other thing I should
mention at this point
is that there's no
requirement necessarily
for your application
to be public.
So another common bit of
feedback that we got was,
we have an
application that we're
going to deploy internally
to our however many thousand
devices, and that's the
only application we want,
or these 10 applications
are the only ones we want.
Why would we look at
using something like Play?
And so we've given
you a way of providing
not just managed
Google Play and saying,
I want to provide a subset
of the public applications
in Play, but you're
also able to publish,
through a private channel,
your own internal applications,
again, through the same kind
of similar user experience.
So from a user perspective,
I'm going into my Play store
and I'm searching for an
application, and it's there.
It's just that you as IT know
that it's already been approved
and deployed accordingly.
And what these two
Android platform features
and the managed Google Play
are really trying to help you
guys do is move
through the steps
and through the maturity
curves that we looked
at earlier from the kind of
traditional knowledge worker
email and collaboration tool
really down to this far end
where devices on forklift trucks
and really rugged, very much
"out of the office" scenarios.
So we have a solution
for the knowledge worker.
We actually have this
device owner concept
where you can manage the whole
device in a very much kind
of traditional MDM.
We have this [INAUDIBLE]
for millennials
with wacky haircuts where you
can have a separate managed
profile on a personal device.
And again, all of
the usual boxes
ticked in terms of IT
just having visibility
into this managed profile and
nothing beyond, and no one
having their cat pictures wiped.
The single-use-- like I
said, COSU, as we call it--
API set where I'm really
locking a device down
into a specific application
or set of applications.
And then really
beyond that, it's
limited only by the imagination
of yourselves and the OEMs
to produce a device that
will meet those requirements.
So I mentioned the OEMs there.
These are some of our key
partners on the far left.
And this is a subset of our
ever-growing list of partners.
But this gives you an idea
of the kind of ecosystem
we're operating with.
So device manufacturers
are obviously key.
We need them to be shipping
Androids and [INAUDIBLE]
versions of Android.
Much like the carriers
and the approvals
that we go through, those
guys, AMM, MDM, MAM--
call it what you will--
partners are also
really leveraging all
of these features that
are baked into Android.
So that's the key
takeaway for those guys
is the features are
in the platform,
and it's the [? MAM ?]
who leverages them.
And then obviously, ISVs are
critical to the deployment
through Play and VPN in a
similar sort of fashion,
and an SI to pull
it all together.
So if we move onto
the Chrome side--
and hopefully, you're
familiar at least
in passing with Chromebooks.
And what changed relatively,
or in the last few years,
was this move from really a
kind of low-price point device
into a few really
enterprise-grade, higher-end
models.
And there's a few here.
The ThinkPad, the Dell
device, and the HP device
all tick that box.
But really, again,
there's a story
beyond the desktop for
Chrome in these kind
of-- going from knowledge
workers on the far left
to signage, particularly as we
get into more exciting things
where we're getting into digital
signage that is dynamically
changing based on a whole
load of cloud-based analytics
or whatever it may be.
Kiosks, again-- another
route rather than the Android
where it can be Chrome kiosks.
And Chromebook's
[INAUDIBLE] as well.
So it's something that
we use hugely internally
is Chrome as a
videoconferencing platform.
So again, similar
to Android in that
you can deploy in a range
of different use cases.
And Chrome's strength
is really, like I say,
is speed, security,
and simplicity.
We've had huge success in
the education space because
of these features, really.
It's very, very easy to
get up and running quickly
with a hugely well-managed
set of devices.
And again, you've got
this consistent management
experience across
different OEM platforms.
So a quick look at
what you can do--
management-wise, there
are user settings,
which, as you may expect, follow
the user on different devices.
Device settings are for
that specific device
and often they're inherited
from the user settings.
On the public session
settings, this
is really for if you
want your Chrome kiosk,
that kind of thing.
And then there's the devices
asset-tracking management.
Who's logged into the devices?
Where and when, and
looking at usage and so on.
So on a user side of
things, what we see
most usage around is
apps and extensions,
customizing their web store.
Route through a proxy's
very widely used.
It's sort of a
non-VPN way of getting
enterprise connectivity,
and right down
to hardware management, such
as web cams in this slightly
bizarre-looking example.
Now, to give you more options
or confuse you somewhat,
depending on the
way you look at it,
what we recently launched was
Android apps running on Chrome.
So you can take a Chromebook
and have the Google Play
Store on this device.
And it'll run
Android applications.
So one of the
challenges or barriers
to adoption, if you like,
of Chrome historically
had been that I need
application x, y, z.
It's not available
on the platform,
and therefore, I can't move to
a full Chromebook environment.
Now, hopefully you can.
You get a full set of Play apps.
It's not a sort of emulator.
There's no need to
customize the application,
and you still get all of the
benefits around application
management and the
store management
that we talked about.
OK, so a couple of
things on deployment.
So this is one
thing that I think
often gets kind of overlooked.
And when I said before about
looking at our strategy,
I think often, it's easy
to go into it saying,
let's look IT strategy.
The answer is we
need to deploy an MDM
and lock down all
of these devices.
But let's look at our strategy.
And I think, yes, there may
be regulatory requirements,
[INAUDIBLE] whatever it may be.
But I think it's kind important
to bear in mind what they are,
and again, maybe
document and work
through these, because the
most important thing is
we see really is
how that affects
the user of this technology.
There's a session,
actually, tomorrow--
I think it's in here at 11:20--
which talks about
how we at Google
do this internally, which I'd
highly recommend you come to,
and some of our
approaches around things
like tiered access.
So they'll go into providing
increasing levels of access
with increasing levels of
security, for example--
that kind of thing.
Because when it comes
to a user, I think,
again, it's often
kind of overlooked.
And we hear a lot
from users of having
to jump through lots
of hurdles, having
their 16-digit alphanumeric
passcode and so on,
and all they can do
now is get email.
And is this a benefit
to me as a user?
Am I sure I want
to go through this?
And so it's key
to articulate what
it is that they get from it.
And so we've seen
some partners come up
with quite innovative
solutions around that.
So I mentioned this kind
of tiered access approach,
or really letting users have
access to some data and only
really increasing the level
of enforcement and management
when they get to
access something
that's deemed more secure.
You don't need to have
two-factor authentication
and these long
passcodes to get email,
but maybe you do if you're
going to be VPNing back
into the office, for example.
So another few things--
so the MDM, EMM, and MAM
kind of plays a little bit
into that sort of tiered
access approach of stepping up
through the security levels.
Select a partner
or build your own.
So this is an
increasing trend that we
see in a number of different
areas of companies saying,
well, actually, I'm building
my own applications internally,
and I need light-weight
management or whatever,
and building at least a
portion of that themselves.
So that's something
that, again, we
have a whole bunch of
tools and resources
to help you go through
that should you want to.
Migrating EMM and device OS is
another kind of common thread
that we get is around this--
companies moving either
between EMM, having multi-EMM,
it used to be something that
was somewhat challenging.
We've hopefully made
it a lot easier.
And also, migrating OS.
And again, as I mentioned,
there's a lot of rugged devices
and so on out there that are
moving from maybe a Windows
CE into the Android world.
And again, there's a bunch
of partners out there
who can help with this
kind of migration story.
User training or
support, again, is
kind of a straightforward,
basic, often forgotten.
And yes, there are such things
as other platforms, not just
Android and Chrome.
And obviously, in a
number of the current G
Suite in other sessions, you'll
see how we can support those.
So a few examples.
Dan mentioned Home
Depot in her keynote
this morning, which
hopefully you all caught.
This is actually a
different customer
that we've been working
with based out of the UK,
but a multinational
supermarket brand.
And they were doing
exactly this-- kind
of replacing legacy
Windows devices,
consolidating down
from the drivers
with a tool belt
full of one device
to do the barcode scanning, one
device to do the navigation,
one device to do the
signing off and drop off
and that kind of thing,
down into a single device.
Customer-facing and
employee-facing tablets
in their warehouses
and in their stores.
A whole different kind
of slew of use cases.
And they were dealing
with multi-EMM
and had this very
much, as I call it,
white-glove deployment for
their head office devices.
So we they were a great
example of where we can--
they threw all those tools and
all those funny shaped devices
in one of the earlier
slides, and say,
well, actually, we can pick
a solution for each of these.
We've got a different
management mode
for each of these
kind of use cases.
And by stepping through that, we
can cover all of the use cases
that they've got.
Another example of where we've
had partnerships success as
well as the customer successes
is Zebra, or "Zeebra"
as I should say in America.
So they're, if you don't know,
a rugged device manufacturer
with their sort of
symbol heritage,
so real background in
warehouse and other use cases.
And when I first started
speaking to these guys,
they were very much against
adopting Google technology
on their platform, and it was
seen as too challenging and too
much of a really hard sell, if
you like, to their customers.
But what we were able to
work through, and really
through these the steps that
we talked about earlier, from L
to M and into N, was
that because you're
able to take this device which
has the Android and GMS on,
you're able to manage it with
this consistent framework,
you're able to guarantee
security, deploy apps and so
on through Google
Play, it actually
became a real strength
and a benefit to them.
And they have really gone
all in on Android and on GMS.
So they have professional
services teams doing migration.
They've signed up to
our security patches,
again, which you may
have heard of in some
of the other sessions.
We release security
patches every 30 days.
And OEMs take those on board.
And Zebra have been quick
to adopt that and commit
to that over a long period,
so for the three years or five
years that a device
is sold for and three
or five years beyond that.
So they've really
been a good example
of where we've gone
from not really
fitting in that kind of
area in that use case
before through adopting fully
our enterprise feature set.
So I'm just going to run
through a few resources
to help you guys, hopefully.
So one of the more
recent innovations
that we've delivered is the
Android Management Experience.
So what we were
seeing was that it
was quite challenging
for companies
to just take a quick look,
try and experience a work
profile and this sort of
application deployment
and so on on a device.
So we created something
called the Android Management
Experience.
If you search for this in
Google Play on a device,
you'll be able to download
it, with a couple of clicks,
set up a demo
company environment,
and go through and practice
with deploying applications
and policy and so on.
So a super quick way, in
just a couple of minutes,
to get up and running
and an experience
it and show colleagues
or whatever.
And then you can
kind of step through
into a fully managed
wider deployment.
Enterprise.google.com/android
has a whole bunch
of information around
[INAUDIBLE] directory,
various solutions.
It has a blog where we
publish a whole area
of very useful information and
links to resources way beyond.
Similarly,
enterprise.google.com/chrome,
again, another great resource
for essentially this similar
set of product solutions
and partners, et cetera,
And a couple of quick call-outs.
So there's an Android
and Chrome sandbox
standing on the third floor.
If you haven't seen it,
it looks like a sort
of garden shed with some
brightly colored tools.
I kid you not.
So please go over there.
Take a look.
Myself or some of my
colleagues will be over there
to take you through some of the
solutions we've got over there.
And if you're a developer, then
as well we have Google DevHub,
if you search for
that online, it
should be the first
thing you find.
And my colleague
Matt [? Goodrich ?]
is presenting in this
room tomorrow at 4 o'clock
on application deployment and
so on and managed Google Play.
[MUSIC PLAYING]